all right so let's get down to the the
podcast questions of the week as I said
people send these things in to me and I
never have them in front of me which
causes long awkward pauses all right
okay
hey the podcast question number one bill
what does an East Coast transplant do on
st. Patrick's Day you already know what
it's like in Boston and in New York City
is it the same or does no one in LA
really care I might have mentioned this
on my other podcast I do not participate
on st. Patrick's Day
actually went out last night you know I
went out I got myself a couple of
Jameson's and I had a corned beef
sandwich and that's it I do not go out
on st. Patrick's Day is a sammich er
night the same way New Year's Eve is a
bunch of people who don't know how to
drink drink way too much they wear green
plastic hats they sing the [ __ ] the
green alligator and a longneck goose all
these stupid-ass [ __ ] songs and I
don't know it's it's it makes me sad st.
Patrick's Day it makes me sad because
when I look at what the Irish culture
has chosen to focus on it's no wonder
we're all a bunch of angry Psychopaths
that even when we go to therapy
evidently it doesn't affect us does
anybody else
Irish out there like you ever go to a
wedding that's not an Irish wedding I
went to a Jewish wedding and I went to a
wedding a long time ago this girl who is
pakistanian and the weddings they were
beautiful it was really a nice
environment it was all about the union
of two people who were going to spend
their lives together and a celebration
of that and you go to an Irish wedding
and the the main focuses is like when
you get the invites like dude is it
going to be an open blah really I'm
[ __ ] there that's what it is that's
all people give a [ __ ] about is can I go
there and get [ __ ] up for for no money
that's the big question then people get
hammered and then resentments come out
and then inevitably there's going to be
a
fight maybe that's why I like hockey
reminds me of weddings I went to when I
grew up so I'll get back to your
question now people do celebrate st.
Patrick's Day out here it is uh I go to
this place out Tom Bergin's down on
Fairfax just south of Wilshire because
it's it's a mellow place they got a
jukebox in the corner they play in music
but it's like background it's not like
you're going to listen to this whether
you want to or not sort of martial law
sound system that they have in all these
other bars where you got to sit there
and scream at the person next to you
much like they scream on ESPN look at me
just tying everything together this
[ __ ] week so ya know they definitely
celebrated obviously it's not the way it
is back east because there's not a bunch
of uh there's not as many Irish people
out here but they're definitely out here
they definitely do drink and they wear
the green hats and all that type of [ __ ]
but there's no parade there's no
bagpipes
there's just the booze we did this is
just basically bare-bones so a couple of
corned beef sandwiches in the corner and
there's 12,000 kegs and a bunch of
plastic hats